You mention that and you mention the pressure on Russia.
It's been reported
that you've got family links to Russia,
that your wife apparently
has a stake in the Indian IT consultancy firm Infocis.
They operate in Moscow.
They have an office there,
they have a delivery office there.
They've got a connection to the Alpha Bank in Moscow.
Are you giving advice to others that
you're not following in your own home?
That's not. I'm an elected politician
and I'm here to talk to you
about what I'm responsible for.
My wife is not.
She is not. But.
But equally, if you.
You know, as a country,
we are asking taxpayers
to fund the UK's support for Ukraine.
We're asking people in the UK
to give their homes up to Ukrainian refugees.
Whereas it appears your family potentially
could be benefiting from Putin's regime.
No, I. I really.
I don't think that's the case.
And as I said, the.
The operations of all companies are up to them.
We. We put in place significant sanctions
and all the companies that we are responsible for
are following those as they rightly should,
sending a very strong message to Putin's aggression.
Do you know if Infoscisis?
I have. I have absolutely no idea
because I have nothing to do with that company.